Elon Musk the billionaire behind Tesla
Motors and SpaceX wants to revolutionize
public transport in 2017 he held an
event at SpaceX s California
headquarters showcasing the latest
technology for what he believes is the
future of intercity travel an entirely
new transport system called Hyperloop
what this really all about is advancing
the state of transportation trying new
things that have never been done before
that can make an incredible difference
in people's lives but is Hyperloop ready
to usher in a new age of mass transit or
is it just a billionaires pipe dream
in 1829 a competition was held to find
the best locomotive engine for the
Liverpool and Manchester railway in
northern England George Stephenson's
rocket won first prize posting a top
speed of 38 km/h widely credited as the
world's first steam locomotive the
rocket transformed how people travelled
between cities almost two centuries on
musk is hosting the modern-day
equivalent of that competition and teams
of engineers from around the world have
come to Los Angeles to compete
head-to-head the aim is to bring
Hyperloop one step closer to reality but
what exactly is Hyperloop in simple
terms the system is made up of two parts
a tube designed to generate very low air
pressure and a carriage or pod that can
travel through the tube without touching
the ground to levitate you can use
either air bearings basically blasting
air to me the few levitate like air
hockey table or we can use magnets when
you do that you create levitation
linear induction motors then propelled
the pot along the tube you get pushed at
high speed and you will steer the high
speed a long time because you very you
don't have friction from the ground and
you're in a vacuum you know a very low
friction from the air
so again just cruise for hours the
fastest trained in the world can travel
at speeds approaching 600 km/h but even
those that levitate a limited by air
resistance today the teams have their
chance to run their prototype pods in
sight SpaceX's very own vacuum tube we
just saw a pod probably not hundred
kilometers per hour we think we can go
up above that but we'll have to prove it
later pod mounted cameras capture all
the action three two one launch
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations 14 that part just went
324 killing is now over 200 miles an
hour it's hoped that full-size pots
running through a much longer tube might
approach and even break the speed of
sound
that's over 1200 km/h that would connect
cities like LA and San Francisco or
unique to Berlin to German cities in
around 30 minutes but even those taking
part in the competition admit they are a
long way from making Hyperloop a reality
the civil engineering part of it has to
be able to be solved to a point where
you can deploy a Hyperloop tube cross a
state for you know a thousand kilometers
need to solve a lot of engineering
challenges ahead like energy and
terminal challenges at a cost of course
and beyond the financial and engineering
challenges involved safety is a key
concern if people are ever going to
travel in this it needs to be absolutely
and completely safe traveling at seven
hundred miles per hour is inherently
dangerous in the face of such
overwhelming obstacles
some argue that Hyperloop is destined to
remain a billionaires pipe dream even so
a project of this nature may well
produce unintended benefits in design
and engineering that could help shape
our future
you
[Music]
you